[Music]
all right if you could say your full
name into the microphone
Caleb signing Caleb signing thanks for
being on the show buddy thank you thank
you for having me so you moved to
Atlanta around 2 years ago from Athens
yeah it was more like 3 now I moved in
the summer of 2012 mm-hmm
and yeah so I guess about three years
ago and in the short amount of time
you've been in Atlanta I mean you've
already come in second in the Laughing
Skull Festival you've been on the Bob
and Tom nationally-recognized comedy
radio station and you just recently
headlined at fest the Athens festival
out there at the Georgia theatre how
have you been able to accomplish so much
in such a short amount of time well I
think almost all of that is due to the
scene here because I I its lucky but I
also I knew that so I went and became a
part of it I knew that there's something
special going on in Atlanta so I moved
here from Athens and it was right around
the time that all the beards of comedy
moved and so I got to meet them right
before they left so when they left and
and had all these open spots at the
club's I they would recommend me so I
got to do I got a lot of stage time
really quickly which is really important
when you're not very good mm-hmm so that
helped and it's also I mean you have to
do and until you have an agent a manager
you have to kind of do everything
yourself and it feels kind of gross but
I would do it I would email people and
be like hey here's my tape can I do this
and one in ten might respond but I mean
if in Atlanta I feel like stage times
the thing so I would try and get as much
as I could and you can get a crazy
amount here mm-hmm
and when you say you would email people
you're taping everything like who
specifically just in the city or around
the southeast well anybody I would email
clubs I I email glass Comic Standing and
just gave him I said hey here's my tape
I didn't think it'd work I wasn't even
sure that was the email that they used
but oh that's just what I do all that
like when I'm sitting at home before a
show that's what I do and that one just
happened to work I mean I've sent emails
to everybody within reason I'm not
emailing Conan but I heard a couple
people got in to Last Comic Standing
just through email so I was like well I
hoped that it was the right thing but I
don't know if they're still doing that
but yeah they probably aren't yes since
I'm telling people but I'm I think I can
tell people that yeah how long did it
take them to respond a few weeks
I mean I'd forgotten about it since so
many emails but yeah I couldn't believe
it they're like yeah that's funny who
are you Wow and I still had to audition
like everybody else but that's how I got
an audition so and I would email like
that's how you you can get online if you
you have a good tape people see it and
they're like no okay because I mean I'm
sure you have this you've run shows and
if you're like oh that person's funny
sure you can do my show mm-hmm it helps
to have a a good tape and a good tape is
this a tape of you at a club or just sit
like a bar situation I have the ones
I've been using or one of me at the
laughing school and then there's one of
me at Epic Comedy Hour you've done never
come here it's just crazy good great
show show and they have they give they
tape it for you I didn't even and I
think that's why the tape was both of
those I didn't know we're being taped
which is I think the key to a good tape
cuz if you know is being take your up
there and you're like cool but yeah I
wish I I wish I could get taped more
often without my knowledge
is that just because you're nervous if
you are being taped he's self-conscious
well cuz you're thinking of it is that
you're doing it for a tape instead of
for the audience and which is never as
funny mm-hmm
you know there and it's less natural and
you're you're not loose you know like
and I'm sure
you know I've seen you do sets do you
want to go out there and have fun and
you want to you know maybe hey what's up
with this guy or on the way here but if
you're doing a tape you just got there
and you're like I'm me and here's Joe
and it's right I sometimes I think the
audience is like what's he trying to do
and I think it kind of feels less
genuine did you find yourself in that
kind of robot mode when you were doing
Last Comic Standing half and half cuz
man they that set it had to be three and
a half minutes exactly they're like
don't go under don't go over Wow
and it was a great crowds like a theater
with like 500 people in it mm-hmm and
it's really bizarre cuz they don't let
you watch anyone else and there's
spraying hairspray on you and makeup and
you're you know it's it's very strange
you know you've been on the set for
hours and hours and and we'd like this
five seconds before you walk out on the
stage someone has like it's like
clicking stuff in your pants with
microphones and they're spraying and
they're dabbing on your face and
touching y'all over getting making you
look nice and they're like making sure
your shirt is still ironed I've never
experienced anything like it and it's
definitely not the atmosphere for you to
be naturally loose and funny and that
you have to submit your set and make
sure there's no cursing there's no you
know you can't be like you can't have
some big anti NBC joke or a bit about
how you not I mean
so they have to run it through you so
it's you're definitely and it's also
that's the set you auditioned with
usually yeah so it's it's a set you know
really well but and you walk out there
and it's like huh man Roseanne's got a
new haircut
oh there's noir McDonald oh man look at
and so then you see them very clearly
they're right there oh the judges and
you're der and your jokes you like to
norm like that one to do and and then
right after you do it like you feel
great you're like TV like it was a big
deal for me yeah and and then right
after that they all tell you how they
felt about it which is so strange
mostly people just say good said or
whatever they don't say anything right
but when it's you know nor being like
that was good
and it's celebrities are saying how they
and there's cameras and everybody gets
to hear it and that was to go from Oh TV
- oh okay
what did i okay I need to work on that
cool so that was very strange have you
applied those suggestions I have I mean
most of their suggestions were how to do
it set on television interesting which
so when you turn on performing on TV
like are you supposed to address the
cameras as opposed to actual people in
the audience a little bit that you
should play to the camera because that's
who you should worry about and they can
add they have time to edit or whatever
so even if that crowd doesn't dig yeah
I'm sure they can add stuff but and to
to do things like shorter versions of
jokes and I had one joke that now that
I'm looking back at it was too long for
for that set mm-hmm
and I even then I knew I liked ah let's
do a shorter version distances but I
didn't I don't think I realized just how
you know boom boom boom boom boom it
needed to be and went well but it I mean
have if you've never done TV you don't
there's some things you just don't know
right you know I spoke with Mia Jackson
another Atlanta comic who's on Last
Comic Standing and her preparation was
just tedious she said she would be on
the phone just running sets with like
friends yeah comics and like constantly
just running over it in her head did you
find yourself over yeah yeah I
definitely especially for for your first
TV thing to also be a competition
there's a lot of added things and to do
it with critiques immediately after it
and that it's such a long process
because the whole things you know
started in august-september for me and
then they taped in March but the whole
thing took forever and I
I feel like if I could do it again I
would have thought about it less yeah
cuz I don't know if the extra thoughts
how or maybe I don't I don't know but I
I did
obviously you want I every single day I
feel like changing the way I made coffee
this morning you know but I I really
enjoyed it and it went well but I you
know I I do wish I had because that's
never the way to be funniest is to well
what you want to do is think about it
for a year you know right you should
just be more natural well one of your
strengths besides being one of the
funniest people in the city is your
ability to network you really have a
just seems to be a natural ability that
people gravitate towards you be able to
carry that into Last Comic Standing and
network there I think it helped a little
bit well I don't a lot of comedians have
the oh you know if you're a comedian
yeah you're awkward and tears of a clown
all these things that I I guess apply to
some but I mean I I like hanging out
I don't hate I mean I don't you know
most people I don't like but I mean I'd
like some folks and I don't mind having
fun and I I hate to think of it as
networking but it's like like I
legitimate like if it's a comedian I
like I'll be like mainly cuz every all
my friends now I saw them do stand-up
before as friends with them you know I
saw what I saw you know Dave stone I was
like that guy gonna be friends with him
he seems cool he's hilarious because
that's you know that's the way I lived
my life before like I was friends with
the class clown cuz oh man he's Casey's
the funniest guy in school I would be
friends with him and you know I don't
have been but then in stand-up there's
business involved with it and stuff so
some people like who networking but I'm
just like no I just wanna be friends
with the funny people you know I'd love
to be friends with Ron White but he you
know it's always he's famous and stuff
so and you can't go to someone's home
let's be friends as adults
right so weren't you voted wittiest of
your
I was voted wittiest mm-hmm which I
didn't really expect because usually
wittiest goes to the guy who streaks
across the field and like pours water on
himself and you know that guy and paints
himself with all the games and that's
every year at our school but then my ear
I was the only guy that was just like
yeah I'm just the sarcastic guy I didn't
I wasn't like the class clown or
anything which I think upset some people
because they're like what about the guy
that takes his dick out he's good I mean
you've come a long way if you're going
from wittiest starting off being
homeschooled you know I mean a lot of
times you know if it's quite an
acclamation process going from being
homeschooled to just jumping into it as
bad as my oldest sister was
home-schooled until sixth grade there's
something like she went from home school
to middle school and I went from home
school to second grade so it was still a
lot of whoa okay this is different I
didn't know that everyone at school
wasn't a Christian because everyone at
home school was didn't there wasn't an
option
they just you're we're all Christians
here you're all my children so do you do
these things and and so that that was a
big one when I was like I didn't know
you couldn't tell on people for not you
know going to church or whatever like I
would tell on people for everything cuz
I was like oh well he did something he's
not doing I didn't know that people
didn't follow the rules of the Bible at
school so that was a weird one for me
but yeah I can't imagine my older sister
was home-schooled for way more years do
you remember when you learned that
everybody isn't Christian you remember
that moment in your life yeah I was
second grade that was like oh okay and
and I didn't even know like the super
conservative way I was brought up was
you know was conservative Christian
evangelical like the whole thing so my
parents would even do like I'd be like
is Bill Clinton a Christian look what
she is and they'd be like no he's not
he's just saying that like my
they would be they they would like you
don't get to choose of your Christian in
my family cells they'll tell you if you
are not gonna be like what Christian of
it now you're not doing it good enough
so like they're even another level so
it's like you can tell on someone for
not being a good enough good enough
Christian which is crazy Wow so yeah if
somebody was just lying and telling them
for which there's no rule in school
against just lying I don't think or you
know or coveting yeah yeah but it's not
against the rules
mmm-hmm you have two sisters and a
brother and I guess you all grew up with
the father he father was a preacher
correct so I mean how is that influenced
your comedy cuz you're not you don't
really edit yourself it seems it doesn't
seem like you take your Christian
background into account to your comedy
well oh that's kind of most it's the
Christian thing is very strange because
there's a lot of weird things people
just add it on recently like like you're
spoken like you're not supposed to have
sex before you're married but even once
you're married you're supposed to
pretend sex doesn't exist like you're
just supposed to gloss it like we'd be
watching Everybody Loves Raymond and
Raymond would get in the bed with his
wife and my mom would want to change the
channel and I'd be like it's they're not
just gonna start having this is CBS like
clue they're just about to speak to each
other and the lights are gonna go out
like mm-hmm
but even marital sex is is you know
seems bad like you're supposed to
pretend sex is it doesn't exist and
we're not gonna talk about it and we
don't go to the bathroom II there's all
these weird things that I'm just like
well that's not in the the part of
that's not part of it and so I
definitely don't dig any of that stuff
which kind of clashes with my parents
but I'm not gonna sit around and pretend
that mm-hmm
sex isn't real you know does your mom
work in the church as well she does she
does like the the they project lyrics on
the screen and she changes the slides
and you know she's like the first lady
of the church what so she does all those
kind of
she's really funny she'll go up and do
announcements and things like that and
sometimes she'll do like a guest message
and she's really good she's really funny
she's very strict and you know
straight-laced but she's pretty funny
yeah you have a great joke about her
calling you yeah crying your joke to you
that she saw that she saw that video of
me telling the joke about her crying the
joke so and then my sister called me one
time it was like hey I want to talk
about your stand-up my younger sister
and she was like and I don't want you to
write a joke about what we're about to
talk about so like people know that and
I'm like it's funny like I'm gonna if
you do something hilarious
telling me about my Stan like I'm gonna
say it because I think it's funny
mm-hmm but yeah I mean it's not just
Christian people it's everybody other
comedians want to tell you how to tell
your jokes and bloggers want to tell you
and Booker I did a club I won't say
which club it is cuz I want to do it
again but I did one club where he was
like alright be clean don't say the
f-word on the first show on the second
show you can say the f-word but only a
couple times I want you to do adult
themes but not too raunchy and I was
just like dude you hired me to come like
well you go up do that bit you just
headline York like it's just like dude
leave me alone a little bit I know how
to do this I'm not the best in the world
but I I know how to do my stand-up you
know I just I some people get to and -
my parents are cool now but there's a
while where they're like man you're
seeing foul language up there and that's
like yeah was there like a like a
boiling point where they you guys had
kind of a one-on-one about it not really
I mean they are it's just the way I told
to him was like hey this is you know
this is our relationship you're my
parents I am your son I don't talk to
you the way I talked to our grandparents
and I don't talk to you the way I would
talk to my friends like there's just a
certain way you speak to people and
mm-hmm and I was like the thing I'm
doing it this is like the way I Hank
there's a reason I don't invite my
parents to sleepovers and I you know I
mean yeah it ruined like and that's what
my stand-up is it's not for my parents
it's not a family like and that's what I
wanted that's why I want to do stand-up
because of the way me and my friends
interact and not the way me and my
parents that are active and so I think
now and especially with Last Comic
Standing they're like okay he's doing
something fine right but it's definitely
not there you know they don't want to go
to a place with smoke and drinks and you
know it's most stand-up is not
conservative Christian friendly so even
if it's clean it's still gonna be people
being like the way these people think is
dumb yeah that's us so I don't think it
they would enjoy it but they're not mad
anymore
it was for a little bit it was just like
oh I start I was 19 so they're still you
know I'm still a kid to them so they're
just like whoa I didn't even know you
thought about these things yeah when you
first started out did you find yourself
trying to emulate maybe some performance
cues your dad would use while preaching
oh for sure
my dad was a huge and he's really good
at preaching he's I don't agree with
everything he says but he's very good at
I mean he does an hour every week you
know yeah he's he's not going for laughs
but he is you know driving home points
setting things up it's so there are some
things and sometimes I'll still go back
and watch him do a sermon and I'm like
man I that's a really good way to like
Chris Rock talks about that like he
loves watching preachers cuz and if you
watch Chris Rock you're like oh he does
do kind of that that kind of thing when
you're preaching it's more applause
breaks and amens instead of laughs but
it is good and stand-up like bill burr
does that too when you're just like yeah
I'd like you you really agree and you're
like yeah he's making a good point you
know or even if you don't agree it's you
still have to respect the point like I
don't agree with I think Patrice O'Neal
says but I love how much he commits to
it
he really believes what he says you know
you're taking doing stand-up coming from
the background you do it seems to be a
quite a somewhat rebellious route have
your other siblings kind of going off in
similar trajectories well it's it's
definitely a level whatever the four
levels of rebellion are that's the four
of us we all that's the scale my
youngest sister is the least rebellious
she still lives in the place where my
parents where we grew up
she's teaching little kids now and you
know very the same sort of thing very
churchy traditional you know promise
ring let's you know let's keep it pure
all that stuff and my older brother he's
in the Navy now and like he was he had
the money he went to Georgia Tech and he
was like let's get out of here I'm going
to Atlanta and he was all you know he
was very rebellious
he was even when he was young he was he
was always been the most rebellious
person he would slam his finger he'd
like slam his finger in a cabinet one
time my mom goes Gabe don't do that
because you know it hurts
and he even though it hurt him he was
like she told me not to do it I'm gonna
do it again so he would hurt he would
disobey and hurt himself just too
because he just loved to disobey and I'm
not that rebellious I you know but I do
like doing stand-up and I like drinking
and hanging out and doing all the things
I said not to do but I mean some of the
things are right like smoking cigarettes
is not a good idea
mm-hmm but you know I tried that when I
was allergic to him so you were allergic
to cigarettes mm-hmm it's not that bad
now but it used to be like I couldn't
like it but I still was like yeah they
told me not to do it let me try it but
they were right about some of the things
but I think some of it is dumb well now
in just a few days now you're planning
to move to Los Angeles yeah I mean is is
that kind of like a small-town kid with
big dreams has it always been Los
Angeles for you
I wanted to move to LA when I was in
high school I wanted to not go to
college immediately which I'm glad I'm
moving now instead of then cuz a high
schooler screenplays are the worst
things in the world there's I I really
hope they're destroyed because it's so
embarrassing what I thought was a good
screenplay and I would have I really
didn't know how anything worked I would
have it would have been bad and I'd had
to move back but me and my friend were
like we had to plan out where like where
we're gonna drive to LA and we're gonna
hand them our screenplays and they're
gonna be like these are amazing let's
make these movies and our parents found
out about it were like guys that's very
stupid and that we got in trouble and
they're like no you're gonna graduate
and you're gonna go to college and I
still I wish I had not gone to college
cuz I I dropped out and it's wait was a
waste of money for me at least which was
UGA
yeah yeah I had a lot of fun living in a
dorm I realize still I'm happy to pay to
live in a dorm for a year with college
freshmen that's very fun and there's
nothing like it it's really everyone
should do that
but I really wish I could have just paid
them to live in the dorm and not go into
any classes and just hung out and had
that cup because that's that was very
useful socially for me but the classes
were I slept in a lot of them didn't I
only work for like a year and a half and
they moved back home
no I'm why I that's when I started
stand-up and I only did I finished out
this semester and then stopped and was
like it's stand-up I can't this is a
waste of time and then I moved to
Atlanta but yeah it's not a and my
parents are if it weren't for Last Comic
Standing
I don't know if the how thrilled they'd
be about it but now they're like okay
this is a real that was the first like
even like hey mom I came in second in
the laughing school for they're like
what like the only thing that makes
sense is are you gonna be on a TV show
that I watched right so like I could
even tell them hey I'm on Louie which is
huge like any community like well you're
on Louie shut but they like went because
they don't watch that they don't know
so that was a big and now they're like
okay he's he's really doing a stand-up
it's a career it's not a dumb he's not
just going in there and being talking
about penises in front of strangers he's
still do I'm still doing that but it's
you know and they all they do think la
is where the devil lives but ma I wasn't
sure if you're deciding to move out
there now because you have the
affirmation from them and Last Comic
Standing
well I've wanted to move out there for
the last two years once I I thought was
New York for a long time
once I start doing stand-up I was like
because it was LA when I was in high
school and then once the sir named Stan
was like Oh New York City because I was
like Seinfeld and Louie like yeah and
you know I visited New York like six
times I love it it's the best and then I
went out to LA and like the the during
the first day I was there I was like oh
no this is it I didn't know and I really
loved it and I love the people out there
and the shows and everything about it I
really liked other than the traffic but
Atlanta's got bad traffic too so but
yeah I once I visited I was like all
right well let's plant me and my
girlfriend we're like let's plan on
moving there and and recently things
have kind of lined up for that and my
parents really love my girlfriend a lot
so they're they're happy somebody's
looking out we visit New York six times
LA once what did la have that New York
didn't well it always works out like
I've been doing the road a lot in the
last year and every headliner that I
really clicked with they're like yeah
I'm out in LA I was just like what like
there's a there's some people in New
York I really jive with but most of them
just happen to live there and so I kind
of started to notice that and every time
I'd go to LA I would have so I like New
York's very fun too but I just had the
the the amount of fun I had and the
shows and the weather and everything I
just really liked
the vibe there I and I didn't I had a
feeling there that I've never had
anywhere else like I just really loved
the feeling of being there and it was
very exciting and it I'm sure it's the
way gay people feel when they meet
another gay person you know it's like
it's the same thing I had when I did
standup like oh this is it I didn't know
or you know and then going on this is
where I want to live I I didn't know
that's what it was
so it's it's hard to argue with
something like that where it's like I
would like if I got Saturday Night Live
I'd moved to New York but like if it's
just up to me that ways just feels great
you went on a national tour with Dave
stone oh yeah another Atlantic comic who
is now based out of LA most of the
comics from Atlanta seemed to be moving
to New York Dave is one of the few that
picked LA did him being out there have
an influence on the decision oh for sure
um he was the same way he thought he was
moving to New York and and then he
visited LA and was like open up that's
here and I I didn't expect to have the
same feel but it was the exact same
thing where I was like oh no I'm just
like that's exact same way it happened
for me and he's he's one of my best
friends so that's that's great that he's
out there and a lot of people choose New
York and I'm sure they had that feeling
too when they went there was like oh
this is where I need to be so I can't
really fault him for it
I mean they're the two biggest cities so
clearly people like like them mm-hmm but
for what I'd like to do I really love TV
and I really love movies and that's what
I'd like you know so I I really want to
be there and I really just love that
city too and I hate being cold but hmm I
could deal with it um I really like
Chicago - you ever been to Chicago I
have been in Chicago
that place in the summer is awesome but
you know they're not not as much
industry there the LA is just cool you
you have performed in Chicago as well
them yeah awesome yeah I think it was
the Laugh Factory yeah that place is
great and they just it's it's similar to
Atlanta there's tons of great shows and
get tons of I did six shows walls there
and only there for a couple days and I
just had so much fun in the comics it's
it's a really it's similar to here where
it's fun and people just want to get
good and there that you can tell they
love it and they're not worrying about
you know career things as much there's
still people here that do that but it
was it was a vibe it was like Atlanta
but you know Midwest and there public
transportation is awesome and I really
just dug that city I hated it when I
went in the winter but I mean that's I
don't like anywhere in the winter I
don't like Atlanta in the winter this
last one was god-awful one of the big
differences though between Chicago and
Atlanta is the amount of industry not
only here right now but that is moving
here is there not a part of you thinking
you know maybe I could stay here you
know its projected Atlanta is gonna
become the second most populated city
for industry above New York by like next
year it means there a part of you like
well well there's there's part of me is
that way but for the most part it's like
you know I really like like there's been
a couple times I almost got a movie role
here like but like a one-line role in a
movie they're filming here which would
have been cool and I'd have been like
yeah I'm doing this in Atlanta but you
know whatever movie it was supposed to
be I can't remember some marvel's thing
you know but like I'm you know Paul Rudd
isn't gonna move to Atlanta to be an
ant-man you know what I mean like he's
LA still where they're casting the
things and they'll film it here cuz it's
cheaper but and they did the same thing
in Wilmington where they had some weird
discount and so people started filming
stuff there for a while and it's great
and it's great for Atlanta to have but I
it's hard to be the the capital for it
I mean Atlanta's amazing
but you know there's still like even
though I could you could audition for
Last Comic Standing here that you still
need to be out there to to do it you'd
have to fly out there you have to and
people in New York and Atlanta when
things start really going well you're
gonna have to and that's why so many
people move there it's like man I'm
flying to LA you know ten times a year
for these things and and so there's a
little of that it would be really weird
if it really did just switch and they're
just like alright Hollywood's no no it's
all in Atlanta now but I mean I I think
it'll Anna will just be a weird a nice
hub as well but I don't know if it'll I
mean it's been LA for the entire history
of movies so it won't it won't switch it
but I am excited for Atlanta to have
more which i think is great I mean I'm
still gonna be here everyone Dave moved
some again a month later it's the
Laughing Skull it's not like I'm just
switching addresses I'm not I'm not
giving up on Atlanta you know I just
don't want to be here I'll be back in
October well you follow it seems that
you follow your heart a lot you you know
you go to college / your parents yeah
suggestion you know you were allowed to
not go yeah I like it was it goes right
from high school like it's me was just
13th grade I I didn't know I couldn't go
to I like until stand up I was like oh I
can just not do this I can just do this
instead but I think a lot of kids don't
know you can just graduate high school
and work for a little bit and save up
and not blow a bunch of money on a major
you don't really want you know what I
mean so I didn't really know I didn't
have because I would always say that in
high school
oh I'm just not gonna go but I was
kidding I didn't know you really could
just not go but to make these these are
big decisions I mean you go to school
you drop out you're like okay I'm doing
stand-up now okay I'm gonna move to
Atlanta now and then doing stand-up
full-time a few years later of doing
that now you're like okay I'm going to
LA the
the center of everything I mean do you
think your background in faith kind of
informs these extreme decisions well I'm
sure I'm there's so many things but it's
like I'm sure that's a factor but I
don't have like I dropped out of college
I don't I don't know anything about
psychology or anything I'm sure it does
but I just feel like when you know
something like I knew Atlanta was very
special and was having a really intense
special thing similar to what happened
in Chicago like ten years ago
with all that crew that's now huge right
and I was like oh these guys are amazing
and very talented like I went to Star
Bar one time what is what I live in
Athens and I was awful at Stan I
couldn't get any laughs at all I didn't
know why my friends were laughing at
what I said and strangers weren't I
couldn't figure out what to do and I
went to starve on one time had a
terrible set I'm gonna watch the rest of
the show and it was like Clayton English
and Jared Harris and Dave stone and Andy
Sanford and Paul Galois and it was an
insane show and everybody was just
crushing it no garden Schwartz everybody
and I was like oh that and they all live
here what I couldn't believe it I didn't
think that exists I thought that was
just in New York in LA and it was in
they're all amazing they're all doing
big stuff and movin and shakin I was
like this I'm moving here as soon as I
can
and I'm like when you just know
something like I don't think of it it's
like jumping off a cliff I was just like
I thought about it was driving to a city
oh this is where I'm going here and then
when things started pointing to LA I was
like okay well let's go there I mean I
don't think it's I'm sure what it felt
the same way if I started stand-up you
know in Illinois and then it was like Oh
Chicago but it's I mean sometimes you
just know something it's just like
getting in a relationship oh this
person's great let's let's hook up but I
mean I could be wrong I'm wrong about a
lot of things but I don't think I was
wrong about Atlanta I feel like it was a
I don't know if I could have gotten what
I got and
where else I mean this was really great
and I think it's great for a lot of
comics I think you get good here faster
than almost anywhere you really unless
you have some crazy like you're Jerry
Seinfeld son I'm sure you can set up
free at New York but is there a specific
event that happened that made you think
oh I'm good enough to move to LA now um
well I still don't think I'm I still
think I got a lot of work to do but once
people started you know saying that a
lot like you're just like shut up I'm
having fun but enough people were like
dude and then I'd be like yeah whatever
and they're like no I'm serious like cuz
when you suck nobody's like moved to LA
like well I'm getting it like it was a I
realized when people like when people
started saying it and I was like okay
maybe they're right and then people
wouldn't shut up about it and I was like
we were right and then I visit him was
like oh I would just like to live here
anyhow this would be great and the
stand-up you know so I mean I don't know
if it was a specific event but after the
Laughing Skull Festival and like I was
so excited because that's why everybody
applies to it because you're like oh
these Booker's and these industry and TV
all these people are gonna be watching
me I'm just gonna be huge I'm just gonna
kill it and and then I'm gonna be as
famous but everybody I came in second it
was great I did as well as I could hope
to do mm-hmm
um but everybody I met was like they'd
give me their card and be like hey let
me know when you're in our way and so I
was like oh that's how it is it's you
just they're not gonna up room be like
let's open up an office in Atlanta for
Caleb you know they're gonna be like get
your ass out here you know this is where
we're at so that kind of really opened
up my eyes like oh I I might need to
really move there and that was about a
year ago and so this past year has been
like okay let's but I'm glad I had this
past year of like doing the road a lot
and and I could get I was more and more
into the Atlanta scene and I love doing
cloud 9 and things that I hadn't done
before really and so I think that
because I don't
I got a lot better in the past a year
that I and I don't think I could have
gotten that much better doing three
minutes at a la open mic and when you
move there you don't want to show up you
want to be good right you don't to be
like yeah I'm working on some you want
to be like yeah I'm pretty good and you
know I I still like to get better but at
a certain point like if you're in LA
it's hard to get stage time if you're
not big and you can get tons of stage
time in Atlanta if you're anybody late
it's so so much so you're missing out on
the stage time in LA but at a certain
point in Atlanta you're you're getting
the stage town but you're missing out on
all the you know bookings and TV things
so I feel like whenever that those lines
cross and it's like I'm getting the
stage time but I'm missing that like
whenever you're you're missing something
from the other city I think is is when
it makes sense did you feel like
stand-up isn't enough anymore
oh it's definitely still my favorite but
I would like like a show like the
Georgia theater show was crazy right it
was all the seats are full there's tons
of people I mean it was you're getting
applause breaks and you're like man and
they're people that knew me and friends
of mine and it was a great crowd and I
like that's what I'd like for it to be
every night and for it to be like that's
how it is for Kyle Kinane now because he
has fans and every city's like that so
and he lives out there and it's like you
got it you kind of need to be broadcast
out there either on TV or whatever to
have that sort of following so and
that's what I'd like like I feel like he
has the sweetest gig there is like every
city goes to hundreds and hundreds made
sometimes a thousand or more people or
can't wait to see him and fill up a
theater and it's you know you kind of
have to go get yourself out there to
accomplish that well you went to UGA for
theater and film whoa is that kind of
long-term goal stand up on the back
burner but really it's movies well I
ideally
every day I would like like Jerry
Seinfeld has the the best setup ever he
goes and drinks coffee with his friends
and a camera crew comes and they just
give him money and he already you know
he gets checks from his sitcom and then
he goes on and does theaters at night
and can get on like that just I would
love to do stand-up every night and then
work on whatever project in the daytime
you know if my if your day job is TV and
then at night you do stand like that's
very ideal for me so I'd love to get
involved in some TV things you know just
doing Last Comic Standing like it was
like seven hours on that lot filming
yeah everybody like people were like
looking at their sets and like and I was
like I know they said yeah I mean we'd
they we had to submit every word you
know so I was like let's you know
there's a camera crew right here we look
amazing got makeup and our hair looks
great all this wardrobe like and they're
like asking us like hey do you want to
talk to the ends I was like let's talk
to the okay who knows you know I just
love I love TV and I want to do it as
much as I I'd love to do that all day
and then go do a set at night and that
that would be perfect so it's hard to
it's hard to add like as I love like
that's why I majored in theater and film
because I love I love that part of it
too it's stand up still impossible to be
mm-hmm but you know movies are cool
Seinfeld got his show super young and
you oh I you 24 20 all be 24 on the 19th
of July so so you're only 23 and you're
like oh I gotta get on TV are you
looking at the Seinfeld model like well
if I don't do it young man it's not
gonna happen uh well I mean I I knew I
had a leg up
starting early so I was like well I
don't want to start early and be like
well I got plenty of time I was like
well let's take it seriously you know so
I mean obviously and it's anybody when
they start stand up they're like the day
you start you're like well I got 30
minutes and I can feature there and I'm
really [ __ ] why am i I should be on
cone like immediately you're like I'm
really funny otherwise well you wouldn't
do it if you did
you're really funny feel like I'm really
funny I should do this and it's like oh
you're not good enough yet and it's hard
to tell yourself that but I would like
to do things and there's you know just a
couple things that have happened I'm
like oh and then you know a couple of
things I'm trying to get to happen and
like what I mean nothing I can really
talk about but just other other things
in that event like I couldn't talk about
Last Comic Standing for forever mm-hmm
but I mean there's obviously I'd love to
do everything like I'd load beyond any I
mean not anything but I just really love
TV I love the whole thing so I mean
whether it's a show or like Kyle Kinane
doesn't have his own show but you see
he's on TV constantly and he's great at
just about everybody on @midnight
he's amazing he's really funny on that
show and whenever he just does stand-up
or I mean so I do love all the kinds you
know so when you get out to LA is first
thing you got to get representation you
got to start emailing people your videos
what I mean I'll probably do it the same
way it did in Atlanta just every night
go out to a show and you know if you do
if it's an open mic or a book show or or
whatever and I mean last time I went out
there and did shows it was just insane
mm-hmm like the shows are awesome and
big crowds and every show I did I was
just like man I can't believe they let
me do this this is everybody else on the
show is a big deal and I mean I love the
stand-up part and like you know things
things just seem to if you are in front
of the right people you know I don't
have representation yet but I mean I
mean I think it'll happen when it's
supposed to happen but I mean everything
that's happened for me so far has just
been for me either making someone laugh
in person or I said on my video and they
laughter so I'm I think as long as you
just focus on being funny write new
jokes and getting onstage I think other
things will happen if they're supposed
to so hopefully things will happen the
same way they've been happening here
but there's no you she'll be there it'll
happen if it's supposed to happen
there's that faith again oh yeah I pray
before every set or you know I'll pray
for the crowd
besides performance I mean writing is a
big thing you have a great blog I you
have a great blog and you mentioned
writing screenplays in high school so I
mean are you continuing exercise that
muscle as well well it's similar to
stand up you suck at writing initially
mm-hmm like I started writing as soon as
I I mean I've been writing the whole my
whole life and they've all sucked and
it's just like stand-up like I look at
something I wrote two months ago I'm
like yeah but he's so embarrassing and
so I kind of when I started doing
stand-up I was still right but I would
you know you're more aware of yourself
once you start doing stand-up and you
know how people react to things so
anything I've been writing for the past
couple years I've hated it so much
immediately afterwards and just been
embarrassed so I do kind of need to have
a little more faith and be like yeah
this might be you know but so much of it
has has just brought me a lot of grief
but there's a couple things I've written
recently that I are pretty good for for
me and I'm sure I'll hate them in a year
but it's it is fun still to write but
manage you just can't beat being in
front of a crowd that's it's way more
fun than sitting in a chair writing on
your laptop when you say you have a few
things you're happy about are these is
this feature-length is this a pilot a
sketch just other things that I might be
because I there's like last year when
some of my friends got on Last Comic
Standing I was like okay maybe if that
show happens again maybe I could do that
and that was my goal and ended up
happening but for a long time I was like
I don't know that seems like a long shot
and there's things like that right now
that are in the mix then I don't want to
tell anybody about in case they don't
have them then I'm
but there's a couple things like that
that I'm like oh man if this works out
this would be really cool but I'm
realizing everything takes a long time
so you can kind of shorten that up by
being in LA cuz it's like out of Atlanta
doing things as it's a lot of emailing
and tape sending and well then when
you're out here we'll look and so it
will help being there for for things but
you know and it's so many things don't
happen and so many things get cancelled
so mm-hmm you know I went live at Gotham
was awesome and then that got cancelled
so how a man like and I knew several
people that were in line for the next
thing for a live at Gotham then it got
cancelled I was about to have my first
big TV thing and then the show gets
canceled so that's like if Last Comic
Standing again cancelled I've been
really upset because that was gonna be
my homey and I got found again it you
know would you still be moving probably
because I got and it's also it's a team
effort you know my I don't know if you
know this but you know Babs my girl I've
met her yeah she got the LA position
with Sierra Nevada the brewery so and
that's been her goal nice for the past
few years to and so she is she if I felt
like oh I don't know if I'm ready
moveable she'd be like well I'll see you
out there buddy cuz not turn him down
like that if you translated that distant
that would be like getting I don't like
Saturday Night Live or something change
in her field so she'd be going anyhow
she's not she wouldn't be like well tell
me when you're ready like she's like I'm
going like she just got the job so she's
almost giving you the push to speed it
up well it also happened to work out
with a few things
that this seems like the right time for
me to move but it's definitely right
time like it is very apparent that she
needs to be out there and so that's also
I want to catch up to her like for me to
get to where she's at in beer I gotta I
gotta be in LA to to get my career to
her level
Wow it seems like time is on your side
Caleb I hope so
I hope so is there anything else you
want the world to know oh yeah I don't
know um
definitely if you're a comedian stop
pretending that you're I know there are
tortured souls but I'm getting really
sick everybody jumping on the bandwagon
because I'm not a tortured soul and I
like I see so many people pretending
that they're uh you know it's like every
athlete pretending they're Rocky it's
like come on yeah some of your just you
just like football it's not a mm-hmm
you know it's not a movie plot and uh
I've heard so many music I'm like you
your parents paid for you to move and
live in Manhattan you're doing fine what
do you like tortured get out of here
like I know I know you I decide infringe
with you on Facebook I see what it is
are your parents still helping you about
no no they don't they have more money
than I thought they did but they have a
Davis they're very Republican they're
like you earn your thing and we're like
they don't they've never I've never
asked either but they don't they don't
do that they're not that those kind of
people they would be like now you're
just sucking off the tee like they don't
know like and I get it you know my dad
still chops what he doesn't need to but
that's how he heats the house is with a
furnace with wood in it so they're very
you know and and now they'd be like well
you're on TV you don't need like even
though you're not just because you get
on TV doesn't mean you're wealthy right
I'm still very poor but yeah they don't
they don't do that
well please let the world know where
they can find you so you won't be poor
anymore oh yeah yeah I gotta pretend my
career is going better you moving to LA
it's pretty it's going I can't really
come I'd sound like an idiot complaining
because I I'm thrilled about everything
that's happening but yeah
Caleb's einen sy na and Caleb's with a C
that's my twitter it's my Instagram I
have
blog that I haven't updated as much
recently but I had blog sometimes and
Last Comic Standing is July 22nd so look
out for me on that and yeah that's
that's what it is and in Joel's podcast
you gotta you gotta listen to all them
thanks for being a part of this thanks
man all right Thank You Caleb sign yeah
[Music]